you might think that you can only get
soft sir at the ice-cream parlor not
true with a little science you can make
it at home here's how to use dry ice to
pretty much instantly make your own
saucer yeah
dry ice you can probably get it at your
local supermarket and know this recipe
will not kill you but first things first
combine these ingredients blend for one
minute
now wrap those chunks of dry ice in a
towel and bash the hell out of them you
want to end up with a fine powder fun
fact
dry ice isn't water ice at all it's the
solid state of carbon dioxide and it's
about negative 100 degrees Fahrenheit
touch it too long and you'll get
frostbite unless you're a white Walker
next we turn pour those ingredients into
a mixer with a paddle attachment and
start mixing on low take that dry ice
powder and add it slowly by the spoonful
like so when everything starts to
thicken pump up the mixing speed and
keep adding the dry ice slowly once it's
got the consistency of soft sir you're
done what's happening here is the carbon
dioxide dry ice is transitioning from
solid back to gas form you know the
state we're used to seeing it in here on
earth
it's called sublimation and it leaves
you with some fluffy seriously delicious
ice cream all that's left to do is
transfer the ice cream into a piping bag
and serve sprinkles are optional if
you're some kind of monster